ce que j'espère c'est que cette
commission d'enquête ne soit pas
maltraitée non ne soit pas maltraitée
comme elle l'a été mais je vous le dis
très clairement j'ai été consterné mais
véritablement consterné par la réponse
du ministre de l'Intérieur Bernard
casenu mercredi dernier aux questions
d'actualité par de PL ping pour qual
exosition c'est inacceptable sur une
question de rapporteur de sa majorité en
plus monsieur Sébastien peut-t qu'il ne
considère pas les travaux de vot écoutez
venez à nous dire que ce que nous
proposons c'est du plom Puding moi
j'imagine en quoi pour vous c'est-à-dire
vous rajoutez au millefeuille vous
compliquez c'est une injure c'est une
injure à notre travail c'est un mépris
c'est une arrogance c'est une suffisance
je le dis comme je le pense et en tant
que président de la commission d'enquête
je ne laisserai pas faire c'est-à-dire
quelle suite pouvez-vous donner
c'est-à-dire que quand un ministre vous
dit 24 heur après la remise du rapport
votre rapport il ne vaut rien il ne
m'intéresse n'est-ce pas en gros c'est
ça circuler il y a rien à voir ça n'est
pas acceptable parce que à travers notre
commission d'enquête c'est tout le rôle
du contrôle du Parlement sur l'action
exécutif qui est en cause un ministre ne
peut pas à lui tout seul dire ce qu'a
fait les parlementaires de toutes
sensibilité confondue 30 parlementaires
vous êtes à côté de la plaque non non il
faut d'abord recevoir le rapport
l'étudier nous recevoir engager un
dialogue avant de jeter comme ça je
dirais aux ortilles je comprends bien ce
que vous dites aujourd'hui vous pensez
que Bernard casenov ne donnera
absolument aucune suite à ce rapport je
vous dis je vous dis que je suis très en
colère ouis je suis vraiment très en
colère et on ne lâchera pas le
rapporteur moi-même et les membres de la
commission d'enquête on ne peut pas
accepter que le ministre qui endosse la
plus lourde responsabilité politique sur
l'année 2015 puisse venir nous dire tout
ce que vous avez fait ne m'intéresse pas
c'est pas possible vous voulez off faire
appel à qui au président de la
République mais bien entendu nous allons
monter au plus haut niveau de l'État et
nous allons demander une mission la
création d'une mission d'information
parlementaire à la commission des lois
pour que nous puissions assurer le suivi
de nos propositions voir ce qu'elles
deviennent comment elles sont prises en
compte par les différents ministre
concernés il y a pas que le ministre d'
l'intérieur il y a le ministre de la
Défense il y a le ministre de la justice
il y a le secrétaire la secrétaire
d'État chargé des victimes et donc nous
allons exercer notre contrôle
républicain sans arrière-pensée
politicienne un contrôle républicain de
cette mission d'information vous la
demandrez très bientôt cette mission je
l'ai déjà
demandéé nous allons officialiser cette
demande l'accord a été donné de principe
et il est évident que vous accord de
principe j'ai eu un accord de principe
du président de la commission des lois
d'accord il est évident que création
toute prochaine de cette mission
d'information oui alors une mission
d'information c'est léger c'est pas une
commission d'enquête moins de pouvoir
que la commission d'enquête moins de
pouvoir mais quand même la possibilité
d'aller dans les ministères
d'auditionner les ministres de rendre
compte à la commission des lois de
rendre compte à l'assemblée du travail
qui va être fait maintenant par le
gouvernement parce que si demain
imaginons que demain il y a un nouveau
Bataclan h quelle sera la réponse de
exécutif que vont-ils
faire augmenter le nombre de frappes en
Syrie comme le président de la
République l'a décidé recommencer un
débat interminable sur la déchance de
nationalité on voit bien qu'on se trompe
de solution la solution elle est en
grande partie dans ce que nous apportons
c'estàdire que nous avons décelé les
failles très
graves préjudicibl notamment au niveau
du renseignement et un certain nombre
d'autres questions